Katrina:  你像雨过天晴一只蝴蝶飞
Katrina: You are like a butterfly flying after the rain.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  这灯在哪开
Katrina: Where do you turn on this light?
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 他好认真他真的好认真
Katrina: He's so serious, he's really so serious.
Choiszt:  卧槽卧槽哥哥哥别别吓我你喝多了
Choiszt: Damn, damn, bro, don't scare me, you've had too much to drink.
Katrina:  你的灯灭了耶你的
Katrina: Your light went out, your...
Katrina: 你灯灭了
Katrina: Your light went out.
Lucia: 没电了吧
Lucia: Maybe it's out of battery.
Katrina:  没事算了吧
Katrina: It's okay, never mind.
Katrina:  哎又亮了
Katrina: Oh, it's on again.
Katrina:  哦不对那是他的反光
Katrina: Oh no, that's just its reflection.
Katrina:  对不起哈哈
Katrina: Sorry, haha.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh, come on.
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello.
Katrina: 你好
Katrina: Hello.
Katrina:  很高兴认识你
Katrina: Nice to meet you.
Alice: 我还有77
Alice: I still have 77.
Katrina:  公园能干啥
Katrina: What can you do at the park?
Katrina:  野餐啊
Katrina: Picnic.
Shure: 溜达
Shure: Stroll.
Katrina:  散步啊溜达
Katrina: Walk, stroll.
Shure:  公园可以压马路
Shure: You can hang out at the park.
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  北京有还有啥适合散步的地方吗什刹海
Katrina: Are there any other good places for walking in Beijing? Shichahai.
Shure: 朝阳公园什刹海
Shure: Chaoyang Park, Shichahai.
Shure:  后海
Shure: Houhai.
Katrina:  嗯什刹海跟那后海连在一起
Katrina: Hmm, Shichahai and Houhai are connected.
Shure:  连在一起
Shure: They're connected.
Katrina:  后海有酒吧推荐吗
Katrina: Any bar recommendations in Houhai?
Shure:  你去跳海吧
Shure: You can go to Jump Sea.
Katrina:  跳海可以吗
Katrina: Can you go to Jump Sea?
Katrina:  我经常看他网上说的很好
Katrina: I often see people say good things about it online.
Shure:  但是我怕也是网红店踩雷
Shure: But I'm afraid it's just a popular spot that might disappoint.
Shure:  不不不跳海是一个连锁店
Shure: No, no, no, Jumping into the Sea is a chain store.
Shure:  你去肯定没错
Shure: You definitely won't go wrong by going there.
Shure:  你去其他店可能会被坑
Shure: If you go to other places, you might get ripped off.
Shure:  但是你去跳海他
Shure: But if you go to Jumping into the Sea...
Katrina: 他的消费是有低消吗
Katrina: Does it have a minimum spend?
Shure:  没没有低消
Shure: No, there's no minimum spend.
Shure:  他是他是一个类似于精酿啤酒吧吧
Shure: It's more like a craft beer bar.
Shure:  算是也不算精酿啤酒吧
Shure: Sort of, but not exactly a craft beer bar.
Shure:  他也有一些果泥啤酒的什么的
Shure: They also have some smoothie beers and stuff.
Katrina:  行
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina:  这要自己弄看半天
Katrina: Doing this myself would take forever.
Katrina:  哎他是不是要
Katrina: Hey, is he missing...
Katrina:  他是不是少了散粉啊噢噢
Katrina: Is he missing loose powder? Oh, oh.
Katrina:  哦对定妆喷雾
Katrina: Oh right, setting spray.
Katrina:  但是我感觉还少了散粉
Katrina: But I still feel like he's missing loose powder.
Nicous: 什么叫散粉等一下她给我讲了
Nicous: What is loose powder? Wait, she explained it to me.
Katrina:  什么叫散粉哎
Katrina: What is loose powder, huh?
Katrina:  你喝酒他抽烟
Katrina: You drink, he smokes.
Katrina:  你会抽烟
Katrina: Do you smoke?
Katrina:  你会啊
Katrina: You do, huh?
Nicous:  来来来
Nicous: Come on, come on.
Nicous:  老板请享用
Nicous: The boss is treating us.
Katrina:  哎呀哎呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh my, oh my, oh my.
Katrina:  你这下真成那种摇
Katrina: Now you're really becoming a rocker.
Katrina:  滚的了就是
Katrina: Just kidding.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  很厉害很厉害
Katrina: Very impressive, very impressive.
Shure:  这也没有爆珠吧
Shure: These don't have pearl beads, right?
Nicous:  有爆珠有爆珠食活爆珠
Nicous: They do, they do, edible pearl beads.
Katrina:  散粉眉粉腮红
Katrina: Loose powder, brow powder, blush.
Katrina:  哈哈眼影盘
Katrina: Hahaha, eyeshadow palette.
Nicous:  他说他自己买的妆前
Nicous: He said he bought the primer himself.
Nicous:  妆前和隔离
Nicous: Primer and base makeup.
Nicous:  嗯对那是散粉吗
Nicous: Hmm, is that loose powder?
Katrina:  不是哈哈
Katrina: No, hahaha.
Katrina:  那是用在粉底液之前的
Katrina: That's used before foundation.
Nicous: 你有散粉吗
Nicous: Do you have loose powder?
Katrina:  不是你这也太贴心了
Katrina: You're so thoughtful.
Katrina:  看见别人的幸福我就破防
Katrina: Seeing other people's happiness makes me emotional.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Shure:  嘿嘿破防吧你就
Shure: Hehe, you're totally breaking down.
Katrina:  今天真让我大破防啊
Katrina: Today really broke me down.
Katrina:  本来开开心心
Katrina: I was so happy at first.
Nicous: 我来给你介绍好了
Nicous: Let me introduce you then.
Katrina:  长得帅的
Katrina: Handsome ones.
Katrina:  嗯可以
Katrina: Hmm, okay.
Katrina:  我在我们武汉理工呆四年
Katrina: I spent four years at Wuhan University of Technology.
Katrina:  没见到一个帅哥
Katrina: Didn't see a single handsome guy.
Katrina:  倒也不是眼光高
Katrina: It's not that my standards are high.
Katrina:  我还真的没帅哥
Katrina: There really weren't any handsome guys.
Nicous:  要多高的
Nicous: How tall do you want them to be?
Katrina:  一米八
Katrina: 1.8 meters.
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Damn.
Katrina:  给你拍张艺术照
Katrina: I'll take an artistic photo of you.
Katrina:  你就这样你这样
Katrina: Just like this, like this.
Shure:  可以可以可以
Shure: Sure, sure, sure.
Katrina:  私下烟酒都来呀
Katrina: We can have some smokes and drinks in private.
Katrina:  哈哈哈特别像我一个表弟
Katrina: Hahaha, you really look like one of my cousins.
Shure:  哎你们都不喝
Shure: Hey, aren't you guys drinking?
Katrina:  再喝晚上还写毕设呢
Katrina: If I drink more, I still have to work on my thesis tonight.
Shure:  几点了哥
Shure: What time is it, bro?
Shure:  10点了还写毕设呢
Shure: It's 10 PM and you still have to work on your thesis?
Katrina:  那没别的时间呀
Katrina: There's no other time.
Katrina:  早上起不来
Katrina: I can't get up in the morning.
Katrina:  只有晚上工作
Katrina: I can only work at night.
Shure:  明天早上我叫你
Shure: I'll wake you up tomorrow morning.
Shure:  咱俩一起写毕设
Shure: We'll work on our theses together.
Katrina:  几点钟
Katrina: What time?
Shure:  8点钟起写毕设
Shure: Start at 8 AM on our theses.
Shure:  你写不写
Shure: Will you do it?
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Damn.
Shure: 我现在
Shure: Right now,
Shure:  咱再来一杯
Shure: let's have another drink.
Shure:  然后咱8点起来写毕设
Shure: Then we'll get up at 8 to work on our theses.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay?
Katrina:  不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  坚定原则
Katrina: I have to stick to my principles.
Shure:  咦好坚定
Shure: Wow, so firm.
Katrina:  等我今天把事弄完了
Katrina: Let me finish up today.
Katrina:  明天跟你喝
Katrina: Tomorrow, I'll drink with you.
Katrina:  今天是第几天
Katrina: What day is it today?
Katrina:  第第二天第三天
Katrina: The second day? Third day?
Katrina:  还早着呢
Katrina: It's still early.
Katrina:  明天还要拍那个yesok
Katrina: Tomorrow we have to shoot that yesok.
Katrina:  yesok
Katrina: yesok.
Katrina:  你今天晚上去学
Katrina: You go learn it tonight.
Katrina:  你来教行吗
Katrina: Can you teach me?
Katrina:  不想教
Katrina: I don't want to teach.
Shure:  我可以给你查拍子
Shure: I can help you find the beat.
Shure:  我查拍子绝对牛逼
Shure: I'm really good at finding the beat.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Nicous: 你他妈也太浪费钱了吧
Nicous: You're wasting money like crazy.
Nicous: 抽这么一点就扔你是人吗
Nicous: You smoke a little and then throw it away, are you human?
Shure:  怎么遭哇
Shure: What's wrong?
Katrina:  怎么着吧打一架
Katrina: How about we fight?
Katrina:  其实我觉得这个地方完全可以翻进来
Katrina: Actually, I think you can totally climb over here.
Katrina:  这里又没有门又没有密码
Katrina: There's no door and no password.
Katrina:  哦也是你们帮忙挑的
Katrina: Oh, you guys helped pick this place too.
Katrina:  他的优势是
Katrina: Its advantage is...
Nicous: 两个客厅大
Nicous: Two big living rooms.
Nicous:  公共区域比较大
Nicous: The common area is pretty big.
Nicous: 他还有一个优势是每个人住的地方比较大
Nicous: Another advantage is that everyone has a pretty big living space.
Katrina:  嗯我当时
Katrina: Yeah, I thought...
Katrina:  我当时一直以为是三个人住一个房间
Katrina: I thought three people would share one room.
Nicous:  差点让你们三个人住一个房间
Nicous: Almost had you three sharing one room.
Shure:  为什么不是三个人住一个房间
Shure: Why not three people in one room?
Nicous:  那你就跟杨老板住一个房间
Nicous: Then you share a room with Jake.
Katrina:  他晚上5点睡你
Katrina: He sleeps at 5 AM.
Nicous:  不是三个人是两两
Nicous: Not three, it's two by two.
Katrina:  他5点睡
Katrina: He sleeps at 5 AM.
Katrina:  你几点睡
Katrina: When do you sleep?
Shure:  我以为是跟女嘉宾住一个房间
Shure: I thought I'd be sharing a room with a female guest.
Katrina:  这话赶紧给他录下来
Katrina: Record this and send it to his girlfriend.
Katrina:  给他女朋友发过去
Katrina: Send it to his girlfriend.
Shure:  你滚犊子吧你
Shure: Get lost, you.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  哎你知道吗
Shure: Hey, you know what?
Shure:  我我们俩
Shure: The two of us...
Shure:  我俩五一一一起回长春你知道吗
Shure: The two of us are going back to Changchun for May Day, you know?
Katrina:  那这不得见一波家长啊
Katrina: Then you have to meet the parents.
Nicous: 所以酒喝多了都可以说了
Nicous: So you can say whatever when you're drunk.
Nicous: 你妈说你妈说终于能见到小红帽了
Nicous: Your mom said she can finally meet Little Red Riding Hood.
Nicous:  你要是带着小红帽子
Nicous: If you wore a red hood.
Nicous: 卧槽我每次跟我女朋友吵架都是我妈哄我女朋友
Nicous: Damn, every time I argue with my girlfriend, my mom consoles her.
Katrina:  啊我室友也是
Katrina: Ah, my roommate's the same.
Katrina:  就是男生的妈妈来找他
Katrina: It's the guy's mom who reaches out to him.
Nicous: 因为她不理我了
Nicous: Because she ignores me.
Katrina:  对就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  但是但是
Katrina: But, but...
Katrina:  这样子的话也有有好也有不好
Katrina: This has both good and bad sides.
Katrina:  那要是你以后换女朋友
Katrina: What if you get a new girlfriend?
Katrina:  你妈不得哄下一个
Katrina: Your mom has to console the next one?
Nicous: 还真是
Nicous: That's true.
Katrina:  唉
Katrina: Sigh.
Katrina:  唉哈哈
Katrina: Sigh, haha.
Shure:  我本来本来买的是杭州
Shure: I originally bought a ticket to Hangzhou.
Shure:  直接直接接
Shure: Directly, directly to...
Nicous: 这个不太好哄就是
Nicous: That's hard to console.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  我本我本来买的那个杭州
Shure: I originally bought that Hangzhou...
Shure:  直接去长春的那个高铁票
Shure: Direct high-speed rail ticket to Changchun.
Nicous:  然后她在朋友圈写了他妈的两千字的分手文
Nicous: Then she wrote a 2000-word breakup post on her Moments.
Katrina:  你女朋友啊
Katrina: Your girlfriend?
Katrina:  哎呀你们俩够抽象的
Katrina: Oh my, you two are so abstract.
Katrina:  不是你你们俩
Katrina: No, you two...
Katrina:  呃你们俩就那个软件上认识以后
Katrina: Uh, you met on an app, then...
Katrina:  那见面了吗
Katrina: Did you meet in person?
Nicous: 网页找的
Nicous: Found her on a website.
Nicous: 见面了啊
Nicous: Yes, we met.
Nicous: 不是这他妈过了一年才见面
Nicous: But we only met after a year.
Katrina:  然后见面就表白在一起了
Katrina: Then you confessed right after meeting?
Nicous: 见面没准备在一起
Nicous: We didn't plan to be together.
Nicous: 准备再也不见了
Nicous: We planned to never meet again.
Nicous: 后来写了封信就太感人了就在一起了
Nicous: But then a heartfelt letter brought us together.
Katrina:  他给你写的
Katrina: She wrote it to you?
Nicous: 我跟她互相写的
Nicous: We wrote to each other.
Katrina:  唉哈哈
Katrina: Sigh, haha.
Katrina:  感觉每个人的事情都很神奇
Katrina: Everyone's story seems so magical.
Katrina:  那就是见面了的时候
Katrina: So when you met...
Katrina:  就互相彼此心动了呗
Katrina: So you both fell for each other, right?
Katrina:  看对眼了呗
Katrina: Found each other attractive, right?
Katrina:  哦确实一开始就异地嘛
Katrina: Oh, you were in a long-distance relationship from the start.
Katrina:  你不是说很抽象吗你这个
Katrina: Didn't you say it was very abstract, this thing of yours?
Katrina:  特别喜欢听别人讲八卦
Katrina: I really love listening to gossip.
Katrina:  因为我在学校圈子其实就我舍
Katrina: Because in my school circle, it's just my roommates.
Katrina:  友然后我舍友几个要么就有男朋友
Katrina: Some of my roommates either have boyfriends
Katrina:  一直高中谈到现在
Katrina: and have been dating since high school,
Katrina:  要么就是不跟男的说一句话
Katrina: or they don't talk to guys at all.
Katrina:  就没有没有八卦就是我说我
Katrina: So there's no gossip. I mean, in my school circle,
Katrina:  我在学校里圈子比较小
Katrina: my circle is quite small.
Katrina:  就没听见什么八卦
Katrina: So I don't hear any gossip.
Katrina:  我们哎太喜欢认识新的人了
Katrina: We, oh, we love meeting new people.
Shure:  我们想想听你的八卦
Shure: We'd love to hear your gossip.
Katrina:  我就一段
Katrina: I only have one story.
Nicous: 说宝宝早安
Nicous: Say good morning, baby.
Nicous:  然后第二天就跟我前女友官宣了
Nicous: Then the next day he announced his relationship with my ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  谁谁谁谁
Katrina: Who, who, who?
Nicous:  我刚说的第二天说宝宝早安
Nicous: The next day after I said good morning, baby,
Nicous:  第二天就跟我前女友有官宣了
Nicous: he announced his relationship with my ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  你
Katrina: You.
Katrina:  你跟你前女友官宣
Katrina: You announced your relationship with your ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  暧昧
Katrina: Ambiguous.
Nicous:  一开始暧昧
Nicous: It started off ambiguous.
Nicous:  后来已经g了
Nicous: Later it was already g.
Nicous:  后来他私信不理我
Nicous: Later he ignored my private messages.
Nicous:  他说他在忙
Nicous: He said he was busy.
Nicous:  然后我以为我跟他就是朋友处了
Nicous: Then I thought we were just friends.
Nicous:  然后我就直接跟
Nicous: Then I just directly
Nicous:  然后后来就跟我前女友认识了
Nicous: and later I met my ex-girlfriend.
Nicous:  就是不认识了
Nicous: But didn't know her.
Katrina:  也就是说
Katrina: So you're saying
Katrina:  你跟你现女友认识的比你前女友早
Katrina: you knew your current girlfriend before your ex-girlfriend?
Nicous: 早太多了
Nicous: Way earlier.
Nicous:  然后然后我就直接发过来
Nicous: Then I just directly sent it over.
Nicous:  我也没隐瞒他我就他看见了
Nicous: I didn't hide it from him, he saw it.
Nicous:  然后他就说好吧然后
Nicous: Then he just said okay, and then
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Nicous:  过了一段时间过了一段时间
Nicous: After some time, after some time.
Nicous:  他买了个机票直接来北京
Nicous: He bought a ticket and came directly to Beijing.
Nicous:  他然后他到了晚上跟我讲他到了
Nicous: Then he told me at night that he had arrived.
Nicous:  让我晚上出来接他
Nicous: He asked me to pick him up at night.
Katrina:  但是那时你分手了吗
Katrina: But had you broken up by then?
Nicous:  没分的我刚来北京
Nicous: No, we hadn't. I had just arrived in Beijing.
Nicous:  然后关键最惆怅的是我他妈睡着了
Nicous: And the worst part was I fell asleep.
Nicous:  没看见嗯我刚起来他飞走了吧哦
Nicous: I didn't see him. When I woke up, he had flown away.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Katrina:  但是我觉得这女生还蛮有勇气的
Katrina: But I think that girl was quite brave.
Nicous:  然后后来就都互删了
Nicous: And then we deleted each other.
Katrina:  互删了后来又加上了
Katrina: Deleted each other, but added back later?
Nicous:  后来我女朋友老出轨
Nicous: Later, my girlfriend kept cheating.
Nicous:  我就不想跟我女朋友谈了
Nicous: I didn't want to date my girlfriend anymore.
Nicous:  但是我就把他加回来了
Nicous: So I added her back.
Nicous:  然后但是那时候没想跟他谈恋爱
Nicous: But I didn't plan to date her at that time.
Nicous:  我一直都是加回来了
Nicous: I just added her back.
Nicous:  然后抱歉一下干嘛
Nicous: And then, sorry, what?
Katrina:  但是你那也有点像就
Katrina: But it seemed like...
Katrina:  在他的视角有点像断崖式暧昧耶
Katrina: From her perspective, it was like a cliffhanger romance.
Katrina:  就是本来暧昧很好的然后突然跟别人
Katrina: It was going well and then suddenly you were with someone else.
Katrina:  四天四天就能代表什么
Katrina: Four days, what can four days mean?
Shure:  四天我这四年里
Shure: Four days, in these four years...
Katrina:  我这五年的
Katrina: In these five years...
Shure:  不喝点了吗
Shure: Not drinking a bit?
Shure:  雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Katrina:  你给我整点呗
Katrina: Get me a little.
Shure:  给你整点
Shure: Get you some.
Katrina:  你当心他进去了
Katrina: Be careful he goes in.
Nicous: 当时我加他的时候我就跟他说了
Nicous: When I added her back, I told her...
Nicous: 就我之前不想跟她谈一方面是家境悬殊
Nicous: The reason I didn't want to date her before was the huge gap in our family backgrounds.
Katrina:  他家很有钱吗
Katrina: Her family is very rich?
Nicous: 我靠他他妈随便买个包都好多万
Nicous: Gosh, she can casually buy a bag worth tens of thousands.
Katrina:  我去那确实有点啊
Katrina: Wow, that's quite something.
Katrina:  那确实
Katrina: That really is.
Katrina:  那你这飞机飞来飞去
Katrina: So you were flying back and forth?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Nicous: 我为什么跟我前女友在一起
Nicous: The reason I was with my ex-girlfriend...
Nicous: 是因为都在北京
Nicous: Was because we were both in Beijing.
Nicous: 然后他妈我们俩都住一起
Nicous: And we lived together.
Nicous: 我觉得我当时觉得
Nicous: I think at that moment I felt
Katrina:  就是在一直就跟他在一起
Katrina: I was just always together with him
Nicous: 后来我谈完
Nicous: Later when I finished talking
Nicous: 我发现这就不是1V1的问题就是
Nicous: I realized this wasn't just a 1-on-1 issue
Katrina:  就是我靠你都同居还能出轨哈哈哈
Katrina: I mean, damn, you were living together and still cheated, hahaha
Nicous: 然后呢我就加他了
Nicous: So, I added him
Nicous: 跟他说了对不起
Nicous: And I apologized
Nicous: 然后我说就是这么个事
Nicous: Then I told him the whole situation
Nicous: 然后他问我什么时候分
Nicous: And he asked me when we'd break up
Nicous: 我说我过生日分
Nicous: I said we'd break up on my birthday
Nicous: 因为那天我期末考试
Nicous: Because I had finals that day
Nicous: 不想分就
Nicous: Didn't want to break up then
Nicous: 我前女友是个很他妈傻逼的人
Nicous: My ex-girlfriend was a real pain in the ass
Nicous: 每次一吵架他他会直接低血糖
Nicous: Every time we argued, she'd get low blood sugar
Nicous: 躺地上可能就要死了
Nicous: And lie on the floor like she was dying
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina:  我靠你给我少搞一点点
Katrina: Damn, cut me some slack here
Katrina:  我等会他妈毕设写不完了
Katrina: Or I won't finish my thesis later
Katrina:  你前女友是表演型人格吗
Katrina: Does your ex-girlfriend have a histrionic personality?
Katrina:  呀
Katrina: Wow
Katrina:  啊你俩谁也不缺啊
Katrina: Ah, neither of you were lacking anything
Katrina:  他分了你也分了
Katrina: He broke up, you broke up
Katrina:  然后你俩在一起了
Katrina: And then you two got together
Katrina:  怎么不算一种缘分呢
Katrina: How is that not fate?
Katrina:  我靠你给我搞这么多东西
Katrina: Damn, you gave me so much stuff
Katrina:  晚上要一直上厕所
Katrina: I’ll be running to the bathroom all night
Nicous: 我初恋在我初二的时候
Nicous: My first love was in the eighth grade
Katrina:  看柚子好不好喝哈
Katrina: Let's see if the pomelo juice is good
Katrina:  哎还行
Katrina: Oh, not bad
Katrina:  感觉比橙汁好喝
Katrina: I think it tastes better than orange juice
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK
Lucia: 哎这现在还不能拔是吧
Lucia: Hey, we can't pull it out yet, right?
Lucia: 那我把
Lucia: Then I will
Lucia: what
Lucia: What
Lucia: 那根线上还写着我名字呢
Lucia: My name is written on that line
Lucia: what
Lucia: What
Lucia: 好吧原来您也看过魔剑
Lucia: Oh, so you've also seen "Magic Sword"
Jake: 开始了
Jake: It has started
Lucia: 我还害怕
Lucia: I'm still scared
Lucia: 我今天讲那个关于咕噜的冷笑话
Lucia: Today I'm telling a cold joke about Gollum
Lucia: 没人听懂来着
Lucia: No one got it
Katrina:  来吧来吧
Katrina: Come on, come on
Shure:  先先先介绍什么
Shure: What do we introduce first
Jake: 你开了吗你
Jake: Did you turn it on
Katrina:  没开
Katrina: No, I didn't
Jake: 先先聊到可心啊
Jake: First, let's talk about Kexin
Alice: 都要进来吗
Alice: Is everyone coming in?
Jake: 对毕竟你收拾过了吧
Jake: Yeah, since you cleaned up, right?
Alice: 啊我的想法就是
Alice: Well, my idea is
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  哦我没叠被子
Katrina: Oh, I didn't make the bed
Alice: 然后这个白色占的面积特别大
Alice: And this white part is really large
Alice: 我就打算买一个床单
Alice: So I plan to buy a bedsheet
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah
Alice: 然后就整体上就看起来被改造过了
Alice: And then it will look like it's been redecorated
Alice: 然后搞一个桌布
Alice: And then I'll get a tablecloth
Alice: 然后这个上面放一个微型的小的
Alice: And put a tiny little
Alice: 小的景观
Alice: Little landscape
Alice: 微型景观
Alice: Mini landscape
Alice: 然后有海藻球
Alice: With a moss ball
Alice: 然后买一个杯垫
Alice: And then buy a coaster
Alice: 然后上面放一个桂花味的香薰
Alice: And put an osmanthus scented candle on it
Alice: 整体就是一个跟这个米黄色搭相近的
Alice: Overall, it will match the beige color
Alice: 一个奶绿色吧左右的
Alice: With a kind of milky green
Alice: 大概就是这样
Alice: That's about it
Jake: 这叫啥主题呢
Jake: What's the theme called?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay
Alice: 初春主题
Alice: Early spring theme
Katrina:  初春OKspring
Katrina: Early spring, OK spring
Jake: make sense
Jake: Makes sense
Jake: 好make sense
Jake: Alright, that makes sense.
Katrina:  嗯行
Katrina: Hmm, okay.
Katrina: 我就搞一点那个
Katrina: I'll just do a bit of that.
Katrina:  然后拿梳子往几根毛上梳一梳
Katrina: Then comb a few strands with a comb.
Shure: 我还太low了
Shure: I'm still too low.
Jake: 好那我们先上楼吧
Jake: Alright, let's go upstairs first.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 就赛博主题
Jake: It's a cyber theme.
Lucia: 哈哈哈已经装修好了
Lucia: Hahaha, it's already decorated.
Jake: 完工完工状态
Jake: Finished, finished state.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake: 还是蓝色
Jake: Still blue.
Jake: 地球地球赛博
Jake: Earth, Earth cyber.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 蓝白相间
Lucia: Blue and white.
Katrina:  你你那个主题叫停电一小时世界
Katrina: Your theme is called "One Hour of Power Outage World."
Jake: 对停电一小时电脑都开着
Jake: Yeah, one hour of power outage but computers are still on.
Lucia: 哦对这是科幻主题吧
Lucia: Oh right, it's a sci-fi theme, right?
Katrina:  这呀呀呀呀呀呀呀呀
Katrina: This, ah ah ah ah ah ah.
Katrina:  从哪开始呢
Katrina: Where to start?
Katrina:  不会从我的吧
Katrina: Not from mine, right?
Shure:  雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Katrina:  我的
Katrina: Mine.
Katrina:  我打算这不是三勾子吗
Katrina: I'm planning to, aren't there three hooks?
Katrina:  他们到了吗
Katrina: Have they arrived?
Katrina: 三个钩子我就是
Katrina: Three hooks, I'll just...
Jake:挂三个钩子
Jake: Hang three hooks.
Katrina: 三幅那个叫什么卷帘画
Katrina: Three scroll paintings, what do you call them?
Katrina: 我的主题叫动物party
Katrina: My theme is called Animal Party.
Jake: 叫什么动物派对
Jake: What's it called, Animal Party?
Jake: 动物派对动物partyOK
Jake: Animal Party, Animal Party, okay.
Katrina:  这边全都是那种画就是那种偏春天
Katrina: Here are all those paintings, like spring-themed.
Katrina:  然后动物的
Katrina: And with animals.
Katrina:  然后这边也搞一个那个画
Katrina: Then another painting here.
Katrina:  就是买那个美纹纸贴一个大的那个
Katrina: Just buy some masking tape and put up a big poster.
Katrina:  呃海报一样的
Katrina: Like a big poster.
Katrina:  然后这边挂一个那个壁画
Katrina: And then hang a mural here.
Katrina:  然后这边摆几个小娃娃
Katrina: And place some small dolls here.
Katrina:  就是全部是动物的那种
Katrina: All animal-themed.
Katrina:  然后地上搞一个那个地毯
Katrina: And then put a rug on the floor.
Katrina:  就是那种苔藓的那种形状的
Katrina: It's like that mossy kind of shape.
Katrina:  然后那那那边还有一部分的区域
Katrina: And then over there, there's another area.
Katrina:  打算就放我的那个花
Katrina: I'm planning to put my flowers there.
Katrina:  然后还有一个那个香薰小夜灯
Katrina: And also a small aromatherapy night light.
Katrina:  就是那香薰既能香
Katrina: The aromatherapy thing not only smells nice,
Katrina:  又有那个夜灯的功能
Katrina: but also functions as a night light.
Katrina:  然后床上放一个松
Katrina: And then on the bed, I'll put a pine...
Katrina:  嗯那个松树的叫什么松树
Katrina: Hmm, what's it called? A pine...
Katrina:  哈哈松树的那个玩偶
Katrina: Haha, a pine tree plush toy.
Katrina:  抱枕然后再放一只小狐狸的那个玩偶
Katrina: A pillow and then also a little fox plush toy.
Katrina:  然后差不多就是这样
Katrina: And that's pretty much it.
Katrina:  对就是全部都是动物的元素
Katrina: Yeah, all animal-themed elements.
Katrina:  然后就是整体是绿色的基调
Katrina: And the overall tone is green.
Katrina:  然后都买好了
Katrina: And I bought everything already.
Jake: 哦挺好嗯差不多5,000块钱
Jake: Oh, nice, around 5,000 yuan?
Katrina: 没事我可以自己自己加点
Katrina: It's fine, I can add a bit myself.
Katrina:  因为反正我要换到我新家去
Katrina: Since I'm moving to my new place anyway.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 我我我我也很喜欢这个房间
Jake: I really like this room too.
Jake: 因为这是我房间原来的样子
Jake: Because this is how my room used to look.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Jake: 现在变成了那个样子
Jake: Now it looks like that.
Tasha: 房间我想要做成一个色彩
Tasha: For my room, I want to create a colorful...
Tasha: 多巴胺的那种感觉
Tasha: dopamine kind of vibe.
Tasha: 嗯然后我决定再多用一些蓝色
Tasha: Hmm, and then I decided to use more blue.
Jake: 你还在充电是吧
Jake: You still charging, huh?
Tasha: 蓝色和粉色的元素
Tasha: Blue and pink elements.
Tasha: 嗯嗯弄个地毯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm, and get a rug.
Tasha: 换个床单
Tasha: Change the bed sheets.
Tasha: 再搞一点装饰画
Tasha: And put up some decorative paintings.
Tasha: 然后那个窗户
Tasha: And then the window,
Tasha: 我想把它那个贴那种
Tasha: I want to stick on something like...
Tasha: 就
Tasha: Just...
Tasha: 相当于是打开窗户的一个景色的那种
Tasha: It would be like the view of opening a window.
Tasha: 窗布嗯嗯
Tasha: A window curtain, hmm, hmm.
Lucia: 这样子他就会有那种夏天的感觉
Lucia: That way it will have a summer feel.
Jake: 叫什么来着
Jake: What's it called again?
Katrina:  你的主题
Katrina: Your theme.
Lucia: 多巴胺
Lucia: Dopamine.
Katrina: 多巴胺
Katrina: Dopamine.
Lucia: 是这个主题吗
Lucia: Is this the theme?
Lucia: 我记得对吧
Lucia: I remember, right?
Jake: 到路亚了
Jake: We're at Lua now.
Lucia: 哎呀我这个牛的草稿还没有打好
Lucia: Oh no, I haven't even finished drafting my notes.
Lucia: 大家就凑合着听一听
Lucia: Everyone, just bear with me.
Lucia: 就是我这个房间
Lucia: So, this room of mine...
Lucia: 他很不巧就没有挂钩
Lucia: Unfortunately, it doesn’t have any hooks.
Lucia: 然后这个桌子
Lucia: And then, this table...
Jake:你后面其实有个挂钩
Jake: Actually, there's a hook behind you.
Jake: 但是啥也不是
Jake: But it's pretty useless.
Lucia: 哦那个后面啊
Lucia: Oh, that one at the back?
Lucia: 其实大家也看不到了
Lucia: Actually, no one can see it anyway.
Lucia: 就是姑且认为是他没有吧
Lucia: So let's just assume it’s not there.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 所以我的想法是
Lucia: So, my idea is...
Lucia: 我可能把这个搬出去
Lucia: I might move this out.
Lucia: 然后在这里放一个小桌子
Lucia: And put a small table here.
Lucia: 然后可以给上面盖一个桌布
Lucia: Then cover it with a tablecloth.
Lucia: 然后我现在想的大概是蓝白这种主题
Lucia: Right now, I'm thinking of a blue and white theme.
Lucia: 色调就是搞一个偏地中海这种风格
Lucia: The color scheme is kind of Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 或者说面朝大海
Lucia: Or facing the sea
Lucia: 春暖花开这样
Lucia: With blooming flowers in spring
Lucia: 对然后这边的话
Lucia: Yeah, and over here
Lucia: 到时候可能还要
Lucia: Maybe later we can
Lucia: 我明天还要再看一下格局
Lucia: I need to check the layout again tomorrow
Lucia: 如果合适可能想放一个照片墙
Lucia: If it works, I might want to put up a photo wall
Lucia: 然后给上面挂一些渔网啊
Lucia: And hang some fishing nets
Lucia: 或者贝壳这样的东西
Lucia: Or shells and things like that
Lucia: 然后也可以装饰一些照片
Lucia: We can also decorate with some photos
Lucia: 或者小的那种照贴画
Lucia: Or small photo stickers
Lucia: 明信片
Lucia: Postcards
Lucia: 嗯然后床单的话
Lucia: And for the bed sheets
Lucia: 就是因为这个床
Lucia: Because this bed
Lucia: 他占的面积实在是很大
Lucia: It takes up a lot of space
Lucia: 所以呃
Lucia: So, um
Lucia: 我还在想是买一个就是蓝色的
Lucia: I’m still thinking if I should get a blue one
Lucia: 就是他的色调和明度
Lucia: With a color and brightness that matches the room
Lucia: 这些都跟房间还比较符合的床单呢
Lucia: Or get two small cushions
Lucia: 还是买两个就是小抱枕
Lucia: Like a shark or some other sea creatures
Lucia: 比如像鲨鱼啊或者这类的这种海洋生物
Lucia: Something like that
Lucia: 嗯然后就没有什么了
Lucia: Hmm, and then there's nothing else.
Lucia: 这个窗帘的颜色感觉没有办法改变
Lucia: The color of these curtains feels unchangeable.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 是窗户很大
Lucia: The window is really big.
Lucia: 窗户外面打开的话就就是对面的房子
Lucia: If you open the window, it's just the house opposite.
Lucia: 对然后我还有一个想法是
Lucia: Yes, and I have another idea.
Lucia: 可能会买一个小夜灯然后就是
Lucia: Maybe buy a little night light and then...
Lucia: 如果说把灯关上然后打开他的话
Lucia: If you turn off the lights and turn it on...
Lucia: 就能有一种波光粼粼的效果
Lucia: It can create a shimmering effect.
Katrina: 像投影仪的那种
Katrina: Like a projector?
Lucia: 对对对是的就很符合大海这个主题
Lucia: Yes, yes, exactly, it fits the ocean theme.
Tasha: 哈哈希望胜利
Tasha: Haha, hope for victory!
Jake: 开灯了吗
Jake: Have you turned on the light?
Jake: 你多少
Jake: What's your percentage?
Jake: 百分之几啊
Jake: How much percentage?
Shure: 我一直显示0%
Shure: It always shows 0%.
Jake:你充上了吗
Jake: Are you charging it?
Shure: 我确实是充着呢
Shure: I am indeed charging it.
Jake: 你好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake: 来吧就就我们
Jake: Come on, it's just us.
Jake: 行行行
Jake: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:刚刚扫的时候
Jake: When I was scanning just now...
Jake:就觉得你这个地方素材挺多
Jake: I thought you had a lot of materials here.
Shure: welcome
Shure: Welcome.
Katrina: 你把花也摆上去了
Katrina: You even put the flowers up.
Jake:你剪过吗
Jake: Did you trim it?
Jake:这个花
Jake: These flowers.
Shure: 没有我觉得它本来的样子就是最完美的
Shure: No, I think their original look is the most perfect.
Shure: 就是雨轩同学插上的样子
Shure: Just the way Yuxuan arranged them.
Shure: 就是very perfect
Shure: It's very perfect.
Katrina: 原生态
Katrina: Natural.
Katrina: 他这自带这种东西
Katrina: It comes with that kind of thing.
Lucia: 好好啊
Lucia: Great!
Katrina: 那他买点那个东西装摆上面就好了
Katrina: Then he should buy something to decorate on top.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 加一点小装饰
Lucia: Add some small decorations.
Shure: 我也我也不知道要买些什么
Shure: I don't even know what to buy.
Shure: 就是哎我我我杂物就堆在这里了
Shure: I just pile my stuff here.
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
Shure: 因为需要充电的设备
Shure: Because I need charging devices.
Shure: 每天就就在这啪插着
Shure: 然后然后充在这里然后
Jake:代表什么呀
Katrina: 赛博人生续命
Shure: 人生需要一些
Katrina: charge
Shure: charge耶雨轩说同学说的很好
Katrina: 特别像老师讲课
Shure: 这个这个就床
Shure: 就是他就他就是个床
Lucia: 具有实用价值
Shure: 对非非常具有实用价值
Shure: 然后如果
Shure: 如果哪位哪位同学想过来住一住的话
Shure: 也也也是不介意的
Shure: 好吧
Lucia: 然后而且有这么多枕头
Lucia: 就是大家想着枕头大战也是可以的
Shure: 12345最多配5
Shure: 个同学一起来
Shure: welcome
Katrina: 赶紧走
Katrina: Let's hurry up and go.
Katrina:  好可怕这个人
Katrina: This person is so scary.
Jake: 这个这个得团队讨论一下
Jake: This needs to be discussed by the team.
Jake: 要不要毙掉
Jake: Should we kill it?
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake: 给我们增加了一些工作量挺好
Jake: This added some work for us, which is good.
Shure: 就一进门这东西就开始哔哔哔哔哔
Shure: As soon as you walk in, this thing starts beeping non-stop.
Jake: 好那我们今天就这样明早见
Jake: Alright, that's it for today, see you tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 下班
Katrina: Time to clock out.
Shure:  下班拜拜
Shure: Clocking out, bye.
Jake: 拜拜放这吧
Jake: Bye, just leave it here.
Katrina:  再见了赛博人生
Katrina: Goodbye, cyber life.